all right Lisa
Lisa uh where'd you grew up where are
you from originally I was born and
raised in Tennessee
just outside of Nashville
tell me about your family growing up
um
I had one sibling and my mom and dad
divorced when I was in the third grade
my dad was a hardcore alcoholic
he got sober about 11 or 12 years before
he passed away
my brother still to stay like me it was
a hardcore alcoholic
we had two grandparents who were
alcoholics
um
my mother was an angel but um
there was a lot of stuff that happened
to me that was kind of traumatic when I
was growing up like in my teenagers and
stuff besides that like what kind of
stuff
um I was an abusive physically abusive
relationship
for about a year when it's like 16 17.
and every single day I would
um
have the crap beat now me every single
day
and I played Varsity soccer and
let's say go away for a soccer game and
come back and this guy would somehow
find a way to be in my home
and he'd be like hiding under my bed or
in the Attic
and I had no idea and this is like
before cell phones right
and I'd get home
go lay down after a long distance soccer
game
and all of a sudden you like hear the
Attic
[Music]
or to be underneath my bed
and he just beat the
[__] you're living with your parents I
was living my mother
she didn't step in she didn't know you
didn't say anything
no
he said if I said anything that he would
kill my mother and my brother what about
the getting black eyes and things like
that what were you getting black eyes
and things like that
no I didn't have any black eyes
that's interesting you know I said no he
never hit me there it was just
um
slaps and punches other places I don't
think every one time had a black eye
but it was a
it was for a year and I finally
I had to leave the state and moved out
of state just for the simple reason to
get away from him
so
and then my dad when my dad was drinking
um I don't know if you want to hear this
but really quick
um
when he got soared up he was the
greatest man in the world
but when he's drinking it was rough and
um I would go spend Summers with him
because my mother had custody of me
right I go spend Summers with him right
and it was just always he'd be like um
you know why your mother isn't answering
the phone because she's sleeping around
with other men she's whoring around
she's swearing around she slipped
and um summer after summer after summer
that's out here and one summer right
before I was supposed to go see him
sorry about my voice I called him and he
was like seventh or eighth grade it took
so much courage
by calling I said Dad I love you but I'm
not coming down this summer I'm not
coming down
and he said why not and I said I just
I said I want to be with my friends this
summer he goes uh
you know what you're a pig
who's your pig just like your mother
your pig just like your mother
so
yeah
yeah there are a few things that
happened in my childhood but
those are the ones that stand out in my
mind
you've been married yeah
I was married and had three kids
and I didn't have trouble with alcohol
at all or drugs I don't do drugs but
alcohol's been enough it ruins
everything but um I didn't have trouble
with that at all until
um like I'd have maybe one or two
glasses of wine a week if that I didn't
even care
but I was married for like 12 years I
had three children with this man and he
uh I found out
I was so naive but I found out that he
had been having a five-year affair
uh with this woman I was living in
Minnesota there's this news anchor in
New York
and she had a family with kids too I
found out by chance he'd been having a
five-year affair with her
and um
I probably would have worked through
that but there have been other things
that happened before not cheating but
like
loss of money because of gambling lots
of just lying but I never thought of you
cheat and so um
when I found out he'd been having a
five-year fear even when I was pregnant
with her daughter
I left I took half our 401k and I got my
own townhouse and but that's the point
is that's when my drinking started to
become bad
I started drinking like no I'm out and
I'm out
and so it became like two glasses of
wine at night and then it became like
four glasses one night every single
night
and now
it's
I've been doing great I'm long-term
sobriety but I relapsed about two months
ago
where do you stay now I um homeless
right now
and I've never been hot like I've always
paid for my own home had you know BMW
that they paid for I've had everything I
paid for myself
but um
I was a living caregiver right
and the lady was taken care of
her husband directed Rocky
like Corner Academy Award for Rocky
directed Lean on Me directed
Karate Kid all this stuff he's passed on
the point is she's very wealthy
but she's high maintenance and I took
care of her
and then um she had a stroke
and so like overnight
she had to go to a higher level of
caring
like assisted living and um
I went through what was left in my 401k
I went through what was left in my
savings
and after that I didn't know what to do
so I became homeless
and your kids are held
they're amazing my two sons are 25 26.
one's a chemical engineer
they both graduate college one's a
chemical engineer
sorry
the other is um
has agreed sorry
there's a degree in finance
and he just gets
promoted promoted promoted thank you
so both my boys are doing great and my
daughter uh my angel that's my angel
she uh
getting ready to go to the first senior
year University of Arizona for uh
international finance
[Music]
but it was a great weather it was a
great mother but the last like uh maybe
eight years
it's been off and on and my kids are fed
up with it like
it's like Mom will do great for you and
then she'll [__] up for your sorry about
my language I should do great for 10
months and she'll
mess up for 10 months you know
but I try
I really do try well what is it that
that made you go off the rails
probably two things one is depression
which I've never ever had in my life but
I think
right now I am do have depression like
I've always suffered from anxiety right
but right now to be honest I think I
like legitimately have depression but
the other thing is um
um
my living conditions right now
and I don't have money to go see my
children
yeah and all I want is to be around my
children living on the streets makes it
harder
oh I've already seen my kids you know
and my ex-husband this is the craziest
[__] about it
I stayed I was a stay-at-home mom with
the kids for like eight years right
and he just kept going up and up and up
in his career okay
I didn't
which is fine because I was blessed and
I'd never take it back being able to be
the state online
but um now he's like a millionaire
multi-millionaire
and I'm homeless
and um
I don't even have money to go see my
children
and the most important thing to me in
the world is to be able to make memories
even if it's just once or twice or three
times a year like did like
go see my children have nice meals or
anything you know what I'm saying
and uh I don't have money to do that
he's got he's a multi-millionaire that's
crazy
and I'm the one who sacrifice
I mean I got I get the gift of being
able to raise my children but still
do you talk with your kids now yeah well
one of them doesn't talk to me
my firstborn doesn't talk to me
because of the alcoholism
he's a great man
he's a great man but he hasn't talked to
me
and I raised him I gave him so much love
I was a great mom it's an amazing mother
but he doesn't talk to me
I don't understand being frustrated I
understand that
you know I don't blame him but uh
still your mom
still your mother
you know
I gave birth to you
I raised you
sorry my newspaper
but the other two I talked to yeah
do you think I mean do you think your
relative your is it your father and then
your
grandparents that had alcohol problems
yeah also dealt with depression
that's an excellent question
um
I'd say my dad did yes
I've never actually even thought about
that but I think you're right yes
I've never had that my life
I've been diagnosed with anxiety
disorder
a different depression but uh we're
going through the breakup you went
through yeah is
no just if that doesn't bring on
depression what will
no but honey I was still fine through
that I was a depression I just was
pissed and um
had anxiety but whatever I just kept one
foot from there one foot in front of the
other but it's just becoming
um without
means to take care of myself I've always
provided for myself you can only stay
strong so long and then eventually
something happens in you
and maybe that's it you break maybe
that's it
this is my housing situation things like
that I never thought I'd be in this
situation a million freaking years in my
life
you started drinking when the kids were
still in the house
yeah when I when I found out their dad
had that Affair in my whole world
shattered nothing's been the same since
nothing has been the same
since
because it was 100 invested
110 invest I didn't care about another
man I care about anything it was my
family my husband my children was it I
was all in a soccer coach Sunday school
teacher everything
I was 110 in
and um when I found out that he'd been
cheating
just
I don't even I don't even have I can't
even articulate it
but uh yeah it was soon after that my
drinking became bad
and I've been struggling with it ever
since
how'd you like to live all over again
would you have done anything differently
would I live it differently
well I would still bury him even if it
cheated because I got those three
beautiful children
that's everything in the world to me
those three kids but um
I think what I would do differently is
uh
sorry
ask for more help
with my addictions to trying to draw my
own
I would ask for more help and I have
asked for help but I should ask for more
because you can't do it alone I always
think I can do it by myself but you
can't you can't do it alone
you know you don't need to be ashamed of
that [__]
that's what I've done differently
it's probably the only thing I would
have done differently
being here in the streets as a as a
female makes it hard
how are you making money how do you
survive
I have a job but um I've been there for
a year and a half and my bosses and
loves amazing men
I've ever known maybe even more than my
father
it's the most amazing man but uh
uh the last uh I worked there seven days
a week seven days a week
for almost a year and a half
never mistake one time I was in the
hospital for like three days other than
that I never missed one day for a year
and a half seven days a week
but uh the last uh
six weeks since I've relapsed I've been
missing work
and um
but he's so kind that
not every day but every once in a while
he'll give me a little bit of money not
much but it's you know enough to buy
like a pack of cigarettes and maybe a
small bottle of vodka or whatever
I'm just being honest
but uh
how much do you drink now I've been
drinking a lot
a whole lot
um
or like a Bala vodka that's like um
that tall
not like a handle but like I don't know
what it's called like
let's see if he's tall yeah and it's
skinny
um
probably one every 24 hours
and then um if I write our money I've
got a few friends that'll
help me out and buy that for me I don't
do anything in return for them not like
sex and or whatever but he'll help me
out with it
and um
it's just exhausting it's exhausting
do you black out or no
no
which is crazy
just hearing how strong it is but I
don't
I think it's my tolerance has gotten so
high I just pathetic but um
I was gonna go to the hospital yesterday
and get some medication to help me
withdraw
because I've withdrawal before I've had
two seizures oh really two seizures yeah
and this is like five days after I quit
drinking and I still had a seizure
and I had pancreatitis one time
so I'm basically I'm killing myself
if I don't stop I'm killing myself I
know that you saw your dad get clean
from it
yeah he did
for about 11 or 12 years before he died
and he's an amazing man
once he got clean
how old are you now 50 50.
[Music]
is the depression getting worse or is it
better
I've never suffered depression in my
life I mean like the normal like when
your parents die you're depressed for a
few weeks right that kind of stuff but
never long term but um
I think
I think I know I know I mean
alcohol is a depressant
and I think that's mainly the reason why
um because I've been drinking so much
and uh
yeah it's getting worse
it's not getting better that's for sure
dear friends
do you have friends
a few
but the thing is
it's hard for anyone to understand
unless they live the lifestyle
I live the lifestyle of being like upper
middle class
whatever that's different right but when
you become homeless
um
you meet a lot of people right on the
streets
and you have people that you think are
your friends
like 98 out of 100 people
are not your friends
you can trust maybe one or two out of
100 people and that's I'm not
exaggerating this truth
so um
I've got I've got one or two
one or two I'd say
and you can't really trust anyone
it's a whole different lifestyle than
anything I never would have fathomed
this kind of Lifestyle until I lived it
I never would have understood it or
appreciated it until I lived it
and the shame must be bad as well what's
that the shame
the shame oh it's crazy
it's shame's off the charts for me
off the charts
and that's probably part of the reason
I'm drinking so much
and I don't want to drink
when I'm sober
and in recovery I'm vibrant I'm way
prettier and I'm bouncy laughing Happy
Just Bounce every step
and now I'm just like fading
if that makes sense
I'm fading huh
what helped your father
a
yeah
he had an incident that happened
and I kind of woke him up and started
going in but he he would drive he lived
way out in the country this is the
craziest thing he lived way out in the
country in Tennessee if you drive like
an hour and 20 minutes one way
to go this one meeting
he went like I don't know five six days
a week in the morning
and then now or whatever it was 20
minutes back
but he he never missed it
and he just uh
it's like a miracle
it's a miracle he got well
it was it was all good he didn't even go
to rehab
let's just say
and the the fellowship
the fellowship I think is the main thing
that helped him
what was your favorite memory
in your life
in Life or with him either one
I've got a lot of favorite memories but
if I had to pick one
it saves
sorry important
there's one night
before I found out that my husband was
cheating on me right
but he's gone he's always gone like 80
90 percent of time right
and uh there's one night
uh
my boys were like maybe five and six and
my daughter was baby you should just
been warm
and I was laying on my husband's bed it
was just me and the three of them
oh it's gonna mess me up the rest of the
day I'm sorry I'm sorry hun uh
I had one boy in one arm laying on my
bed I had one boy in one arm the other
boy there I had my daughter on my chest
and for some reason I thought
uh remember this
I remember this moment
remember this moment Lisa because
it's not gonna come around again you got
all three of your children right here
and your arms on your head body and uh
they all went to sleep
and I just laid there before I went to
sleep for like a half an hour just to
like Savor Savor that morning
that's probably my all-time favorite and
I made my whole life
sorry he'll cry
I haven't thought about that a long time
sorry
I said what would you say is your
greatest strength
my greatest strength is uh
I'm resilient
doesn't seem like it right now but I am
and I love people I have so much
compassion and love for people too much
probably
foreign
what's your biggest fear now
it's not even dying you think I'd say
dying
my biggest fear is I just don't uh sorry
you gotta stop crying because when I cry
why not
my biggest fear is going too long
without seeing my children
because it's almost like a year since
I've seen them
um I just saw him recently but uh not
the one that doesn't talk to me but the
other two I've seen recently and um
they're amazing they're freaking amazing
they're gorgeous they're caring they're
compassionate they care about people but
uh my biggest fear is I don't
want to go too long without seeing my
children
it's not even dying it says it won't go
that long without seeing my kids again
you know
sorry
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
let me think about that for one second
most important lesson
I would say that I've learned a lot of
lessons actually considering my age but
um if I had to pick one lesson I would
say
my mother was an angel my dad after he
got sober was amazing I would say um
most important lesson is
don't count anybody out like don't give
up
if it's your loved one or someone you
care about or a friend don't give up on
them you know just uh
have some compassion
and uh
they'll come back around
and I know I will too
but I did that with my dad and my mother
taught me that the compassion and not to
judge
my mother taught me don't judge anybody
and I don't and who am I to judge
anybody right now
but uh my mother was amazing she was a
respiratory therapist
she's an angel but she taught me don't
ever judge anybody
does it matter like where nationality or
the color of their skin or their
religious beliefs or politically nothing
it's about like kind of like Martin
Luther King said like the content of the
character
my mother taught me and I believe that
firmly
um so just don't judge people
and give people a chance
all right Lisa thank you so much for
sharing your story
thank you I wish you the best of luck
thank you hi
maybe you can do what your dad did I
will